Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Cuphead. I've calmed down a bit
I don't know why I was mad in the first place
But let's go into the third mausoleum and see if we can get our last super
I don't know my slappa skills may need some work
Well these guys are getting kind of antsy about this- sorry i just went silent as I was trying to concentrate there
I don't know why it's not gonna make anything different. My skills are exactly as they were
Whoa you are weird. I don't like
What the hell what can I?
no that was too close oh
God these slappa assholes think that they can be me oh I see oh shit. It's alright. That's right
No oh no it was right there with the slappa cock, god damn, and I had that in the bag
I don't know why I could add it first try but no I gotta be stupid
Goddamn  why'd that happen?
No no-oh
God damn it damn. It damn. It damn. It damn. It damn it damn it damn
It damn it damn damn damn damn damn damn damn damn it damn it
Huh these guys are really gettin' antsy, antsy in my pantsy alright, but I'm getting the best of them
Aw, you big slappa bitch, Alright,
got 'em
HEY, I'm the slappa king!
You think i am not the king of slappa? Yeah!
hoooooo
Give me the magic baby, I don't know how good the invulnerability is gonna do me
But-- thank goodness you came by I was a stupid idiot and went into another mausoleum and got trapped again
Here's the last magical super art. I was able to find for you
Well time for me to take a powder good luckk alright. See ya see ya, baby. Ghost lady alright. I love you
You little sand guy
BOOM! dead, I guess alright unlock the new super alright
Let's see what that one's about giant ghost: maneuver your spirit and body simultaneously for maximum damage
Alright you know what I'll give it a try. I don't know what that means but I'll do it. I suppose, what do we got at the shop
Hello, porkrine
Thanks how 'bout this one, whatever that means, this
Whoa coffee super meter continuously fills in addition to what you earn. Oh, that's handy, i like that
Whetstone: your first parry moves doubles as a damaging- OHHH
ooooOOOOOOO
That's a handy dandy thing-amabig
Okay, all right well
that's something to look forward to- hey, hows it goin' Forky? Not everyone has a grade A
rating if you know what I mean and not everyone can maintain that level of quality over time
Consistency my dear friends that is what it's all about
Then you will experience the scintillating sensations that I do, alright. I don't know what that means, but whatever okay?
Thanks for being a kind of a douche. I guess murine corpse
All right, whatever just so long as I can use my precision strike on you. uh, oh that seems bad
Oh come on! That was a slappa!
Whoa
Okay, I see what's going on there. This ain't so bad, whoah okay
That's pretty bad with the explody there that zoth was easy as ein zwei
Drei oh, one two three. Why do you guys have to be German so, I gotta watch out for not only the bombs
But there after blows
No, I ran right into that one. That was my bad. Why is there a- wait, what was that outside?
*unintelligible*
it looked like there was something outside. oh come on! give me my goddamn super. I slappa is in need of more slappa, slappa nappa
Whoa god damn it. What did I just do? Oh, Hey, How's it going? Well, This is weird, okay
Well, that's strange. Okay. I'm dead I didn't know that was gonna happen
Okay, all right, then well, that's no good. I got it, I got it, i got it, i got it, i got it
Okay, I don't know what this does, but here we go! whobo- oh, well, that's- Ohhh
What the heck is- what, why- didn't know how that worked?
I-I was just I don't know what happened but to be perfectly honest. I have no idea. Okay. That's weird okay
This is this bizarre. Hey. Let me get a good shot of ya. No not jump. Oh, there's a second level
Oh, that's handy. Oh that ain't good. Oh that ain't good either
Okay, the fire. Yeah, okay, the fire the fire the fire. Okay. I should switch to my other weapon to that stage
Come on
Why are there so many butt plugs on the back shelf over there by the way come on come on come on come on you?
Cherry bomb blast and bastard you thinking me huh again?
I don't know what this is gonna do, but I'm gonna try all right here. We go this thing
apparently wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb wobb
ow sack of shit ah
Well the fire. Also is a thing that is a thing okay?
But it it seems like that thing did a lot of damage. It did a lot of damage all right
I'm gonna mess up your butt plug collection bro broham.
You think your butt plugs are safe for me nan sir is no
Okay, yeah, see you're out of here. You're at this stage of desperation. Yeah, I see how it is
habalubububub
Ba ba ba ba ba okay get that get that yeah, that's the stuff, okay, I see I see what's going on here
Okay, okay, okay, okay? Oh Oh?
Haha dodged your bitch all right. That's not good. Okay. Okay. Okay? Okay there we go there
We go got him got him. Whoa whoa way that's that's awful. That's okay. You know
*untelligable*
wow
Wow, wow wow wow wow wow you all right? That's awful. That's horrible. That's no good
I don't want to slap on that. I don't want to slap anything about that ghosty ghosty
*groan
Ghost slaps are not what i signed up for but here's a GHOST SLAP BABY, GET SLAPPED
whoaaaahhh get slapa
Baby okay, Jesus ah what is that what my heart? I want to slap her that house shit
I shouldn't have slap at that. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy
What the hell?
No no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no and about that oh Jesus
Oh jeuzums o je-NOOOO
How close was I
noOOOOO
God damn it god
bulububua
Okay, go go go go get him get him hit em hard hit em hard hit him real hard
That's the good stuff. Oh, that's the good stuff right there. I don't even know it's coming out. Oh shit
Why I was dry. I don't know what I'm doing. I don't know what I'm doing
I don't know. Oh Frick come on really really oh come on
Goddamn it. I did I didn't switch my other weapon is my problem there. Okay watch this
This is gonna be the one I got this anybody who doubts me is down the wrong horse
You got to place your bets now
There's gonna be the one if there was a way a betting system on YouTube you have our stock betting right now
You're ready for your loot boxes of
Welp who lost their bet then who won their bet I bet yeah, yeah, okay, yep here, we go unleash the beast within
Unleash well, that's okay there. We are there. We are there. We are there. We are. Okay switching weapon no fire
I've almost forgot about the fire that very important fire thing
But the fire is the only thing that I need to remember in this entire endeavor is
Literally the only thing that I need to remember is the fire everything else is just super easy oh, no oh no
Oh, no. Oh, no here. We go. Oh, no he lost control. Oh, that's so sad. I guess oh well
He's very dead all right Kat. You can't bastard you think you mess with me
Ah nan sir is no the case. It wasn't clear oh
Really the tiles are gonna start on that end
I
Slap I slap up. I slap I slappa I slap up I slap it
No, register my slap off this guy is not that hard. I do not know why I'm having so much trouble with him
He's really not that hard. This is actually quite simple and yet, I'm just being a stupid
That's all I'm really doing I'm just being stupid
You know you guys know how I like been stupid and all that that's me right now. Oh
Babe, oh, babe, mmm there we go. That's the good stuff. That's the goods welp there. He goes
I guess that's not the good stuff anymore
Oh boy
Whoa God again with the stupid thing?
The fire the only thing I need to remember this entire match the only
thing the only
Thing I need to remember is the fire it's the only
Thing say it with me the only thing I need to remember is you do fire?
do fire if
That was me being stupid. Okay. This is the one
You know why cuz I got a dad a slap-up
And that's our up Dodger dad a slapper to that also an option if me really am think about it real hard
That's fast
You know why cuz I'm so good ah okay the fire. It's the only thing. I need to remember
The only thing I need to remember is it the fire the fire is the?
Only thing I need to remember oh, oh the fire
Only thing I need to remember
The fire like I he was dead, and I just jumped into that for no reason there was no reason
I should have done that absolutely no reason well. That's awful again. That's very awful now boy
Nah, really really really really how about you get some of this ghosts power, baby?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay? Ah I'm so this guy is not that hard. It's not hard
Okay, all right, okay?
I got this I got this the only thing that I need to worry about is
the fire which I just almost got hit by
Because I was trying to dodge something else, but again not that big a deal in the face of
Certain dumb like that not that big a deal cuz I got this on lock
I'm watching out for tiles and ghost poop the pink goes deep up it ain't gonna do
Nothin, cuz I have got an eye for quality
slapper and
Agusta go star with the horse to Moscow. Whoa whoa whoa whoa okay? Got hit by that, but that was not a fly
If I get hit again, I'm gonna be so mad if I get hit again
I'm gonna be so mad if I come to this last phase I get hit too stupid times
Cuz I'm dumb that
Don't do it. Don't do it. Okay. I see you know I saw you on the ground I
Saw you on the ground slap up no
This is not that art, I don't get why I'm having so much trouble with this duck and cover
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Yeah, yeah, be scared. Be scared you be scared
I'm not scared because I'm the real hunter here. You gonna get blamed many times
Emma cat lady if you are
that thing slap
intensify
God I slap with that I did I did I did I did it. I swear I slap at that
Fuck it's just me no
again
Fuck ah it's just me trying to slap a things. That's the only thing. It's just me trying to get a slap up
I don't need it. I don't need it. Why am I going for it the fire is the only?
thing that I need to worry about
That's not good, but I can
Survive it. I know what I'm doing because I'm smart and full of poop
I have to poop did I mention I have to poop okay? See this is easy
I don't know why I was even trying with the other cannon before because it's not
Necessary there we go that's a slappa if ever I saw
Seems
bad
Okay, we're fine. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine. We're fine
What what was that? What was that what the hell oh?
Come on
Why why why I just lose focus for like a second bam bam
Get dead just died already just died. Yes. Fuck you get out of there. Oh you lying piece of shit
Oh using the ghosts of your family to fuel your stupid ambitions. Fuck you you weren't that hard I still maintain
It was not that difficult. I had that in the bag not my fault
I also had the wrong weapon for it should add like the spread can and that would have been great for it whatever gotten a
- that's all that matters Frank so anyway, that's all the time I got for this episode
I don't know why that took so long, but I got it. So thank you everybody so much for watching
Let me know your think of this and thank you everybody for being there with me
Let me know if you want to see more cut bad bomb probably are we gonna do it
So I love this so much Werner warming, so thank you again and as always I will see you in the next video